happening right now the public is paying  its respects to Fallen Metro officer  trong Tai this is a live look at the  visitation which is happening at the  King David Memorial Chapel this started  at five o'clock it's going to wrap up  we're told at about eight o'clock the  funeral service itself is happening  tomorrow at Central Church over in  Henderson now that service begins at 10  but before that there will be a  procession it's planned to start at 8 30  in the morning they'll be coming from  the mortuary the Palm downtown Mortuary  at 8 30 and then there will be uh  proceeding over to the church at 10 and  of course we'll be carrying that live  for you on 8 News Now